[Musique]
depuis trois ans d'amener une politique
de droite je vous réponds non
en matière régaliennes est ce que c'est
la politique d'un gouvernement de droite
ce que nous assistons est ce que c'est
être être de droite que de qualifier
d'incivilité l'assassinât de bayonne et
celui d'agen on sent effectivement au
delà d'un laxisme d'ailleurs un
décrochage total de l'autorité de l'état
sur toute la chaîne qui composent la
sécurité vous savez bon même s'il vient
de changer de ministre de l'intérieur il
suffit de discuter avec les forces de
sécurité avec les policiers sur le
terrain pour voir à quel point ils sont
écoeurés décourager de cette aversion
qu'il y a des valeurs dans notre pays
aujourd'hui
vous parliez de laxisme vous parliez de
hausse de la délinquance qui est une
réalité on est moins la même chose est
que la macro ni depuis trois ans et le
fossé qui entre les paroles et les actes
- une manuelle moqueront qui montre du
muscle devant les caméras de télévision
et puis quand il faut agir il est pas
toujours au rendez-vous pour toute la
chaîne qui composent la sécurité
publique on voit que le gouvernement est
totalement absent mails macron
m'habituer à faire la distinction entre
les discours et les actes j'entends
j'entends les mots j'attends maintenant
les actes j'attends par exemple que
monsieur dupont moretti tourner le dos à
la politique pénale de m taubira de
madame belloubet il faut qu'on en
finisse avec les zones de non droit il
faut qu'on en finisse avec le sentiment
d'impunité
on écoute emmanuel macron on a
l'impression que la garde gagner au loto
c'est noël en juillet tout est
magnifique
maintenant effectivement il ya une
relance de l'économie qui est nécessaire
et elle devrait même être plus rapide
parce que là on parle d'argent qui va
être investi qu'en 2021 2022 2023 ça
nous renvoie quand même déjà très très
loin quand on sait la catastrophe
économique qu'on a devant nous à
l'automne dans cet accord la france
n'est pas véritablement gagnant puisque
elle va contribuer davantage au budget
de l'ue qu'elle ne percevra donc il y a
tout de même
des limites des limites à cet accord
vous pensez que c'est une avancée pour
l'europe moi je peux émettre des doutes
parce que on est en train de mutualiser
une dette donc on va devoir lever de
l'impôt européen
pas de lisibilité sur ce plan de relance
beaucoup de recul et sur des sujets
essentiels que quand vous mutualiser une
dette de savoir à qui vous prêtez et les
modalités de remboursement
accra telecel la voyez ils se sont mis
d'accord pour emprunter ils se sont mis
d'accord pour dépenser
j'ai vu le présent la république venir
hier soir au 20 heures de tf1 et je n'ai
pas compris comme d'ailleurs je pense
tous les français comment il allait
rembourser qui paye à la fin des fins
parce que quand on sur un accord de 750
milliards d'euros où il y avait des
prêts et un certain nombre de
subventions
à la fin il ya quelqu'un qui paie
l'addition et nous ce qu'on veut c'est
que ce soit pas les français et pour pas
que ça soit les français il faut pas
qu'on ait un impôt européen
[Musique]